Catherine tricot est-ce que ce matin on
peut dire que la colère des agriculteurs
la crise agricole est derrière nous
alors la colère des agriculteurs
retomberé oui la crise agricole derrière
nous non c'estàd qu'on sait très bien
que c'est un problème très complexe qui
touche à au croisement de deux grandes
questions c'estàd le revenu des
agriculteurs et puis la nécessaire
transformation de notre modèle agricole
et là c c'est ce deuxième élément enfin
les deux d'ailleurs ne sont en aucun cas
résolus on a débloqué 400 millions de
d'aide aux agriculteurs il y a 400000
exploitation agrices donc on a débloqué
à peu près 1000 € par exploitation
agricole tout le monde comprend bien que
ça ne peut pas régler le problème donc
la question des revenus agricoles n'est
pas résolu et celle de la transformation
agricole qui ne peut pas contourner la
question écologique de tout point de vue
et la biodiversité et la question de
l'eau et je dirais même que ce weekend
ça a plutôt je pense aggravé la question
c'estàdire qu'on on a vraiment un une
remontée enfin moi ce weekend j'ai un
peu regardé les reportages les journaux
tout le monde montre l'émotion que crée
en fait ce pas en arrière qu'a fait le
gouvernement soi-disant pour faire une
concession mais qui en fait heurte et
les agriculteurs et les citoyens on va
parler de la question écologique dans
quelques instants mais Yve est-ce que
vous diriez que Gabriel hatal a réussi à
éteindre la colère alcole est-ce qu'il a
bien géré cette crise sa première à
Matignon alors la crise elle est pas
terminée bien sûr elle va durer tout le
20e tout le 21e siècle de façon évidente
euh parce qu'on aura toujours euh
production écologie il y aura toujours
des chocs je dirais et on est dans un
choc de civilisation moi j'en suis
persuadé c'estd qu'il faut qu'on change
nos moyens de no nos nos façons de
produire ça c'est ça paraît assez
inéluctable euh après gabrielal je
trouve qu'il a bien gérer cette histoire
parce qu'il a pas laissé le mouvement
s'enflammer le mouvement était puissant
il est était très revendicatif il était
dangereux euh pour
euh il pouvait très vite euh sortir de
tout contrôle et je trouve qu'il l'a
plutôt assez bien géré assez à l'écoute
quand même de de du monde agricole alors
évidemment il a été obligé de faire des
concessions il a été obligé de on va
dire de revenir en arrière sur certaines
euh certaines promesses notamment
écologiques je dis promesses parce que
elle n'était pas encore en en en était
pas encore entré en application donc
voilà il a mais je trouve qu'il a plutôt
bien géré il a bien géré quand même
Catherine ou pas ah il a éteint la
colère enfin je veux dire les tracteurs
sont rentrés ça c'est incontestable il a
fait des concessions à une partie du
monde agricole parce que ce n'est pas
tout le monde agricole qui le demandait
la Confédération paysane on ne sait qui
elle est pour développer une agriculture
plus paysane plus vivrière et avec plus
de compatibilité écologique elle elle
est absolument pas d'accord avec ses
concessions mais même je je dirait la
Coordination Rurale moi j'étais dans
dans une émission avec la
vice-présidente de la Coordination
rurale qui disait mais nous on demande
pas un retour sur les enjeux écologique
ce qu'on demande c'est de pouvoir le
faire et de pouvoir vivre de notre
métier c'est qu'il a choisi de de de de
de donner raison à la FNSA donc tout le
monde sait qu'elle en fait cogère depuis
des décennies avec le gouvernement
l'agriculture et donc il a donné raison
à ce groupe la FNSEA qui représente
malgré tout que 35 à 40 % des
agriculteurs c'est ce n'est même pas la
majorité et c'est un groupe qui qui est
notamment très influent parmi les grands
agriculteurs céréaliers en notamment
enfin ceux qui vont vers l'exportation
c'estàdire que je crois que le problème
et moi je rejoins Yve quand il dit que
c'est un enjeu qui est un enjeu du
siècle c'està-dire il faut faire une
transformation de notre agriculture et
je pense moi que la question de
l'objectif d'avoir une agriculture
exportatrice doit être contesté doit
être en tout cas à tout le moins discuté
ça rapporte 10 milliards de de de de
dollars n'importe quoi d'euros dans la
balance commerciale c'est tout à fait
certain mais de mais ces 10 milliards on
le fait on paye aussi que plus de la
moitié des fruits et légumes que nous
consommons sont importés c'est-à-dire
qu'on nous n'avons en aucune façon de
souveraineté alimentaire ça c'est
vraiment ce payer de mots que de le dire
et si on veut donner cet objectif là à
notre agriculture il faut discuter le
fait qu'elle soit exportatrice et c'est
mauvais pour juste réserver la
production française à la France en
priorité pour c'estàdire c'est c'est
orienter la production agricole vers les
besoin de des 67 bientôt 70 millions de
Français que nous sommes et je dirais
c'est bon pour notre agriculture pour
notre écologie mais c'est aussi il faut
se rendre compte que c'est totalement
destructeur cette cette idée de
l'agriculture qui s'exporte dans le
monde entier elle est destructrice pour
notre environnement notre écosystème à
l'échelle planétaire et elle détruit
l'agriculture paysane dans les pays du
Sud donc c'est très mauvais ça fait 20
ans par exemple que des gens comme la
Confédération paysane disent que ce
système là est mauvais pour tout le
monde à à toutes les échelles sur la
planète et je moi je suis contente que
on en discute là en fait c'est une
discion qui na jamais vraiment eu lieu
Yve est-ce qu'il faut moins exporter
voir cesser d'exporter non je pense que
ce que ce qui vient d'être dit est
complètement irréaliste enfin c'est on
va pas vivre comme robasson crusé on va
fermer toutes les frontières on fait
plus rien et on vit chacun chez soi
parce que ce qui est valable pour
l'agriculture il faut le répliquer à ce
moment-là sur tous les secteurs
d'activité soyons raisonnablees et
ouvrons les yeux on n'est pas dans ce
mondelà on est dans un monde où qui est
complètement ouvert et alors autant je
suis d'accord pour dire qu'il faut
renforcer les capacités nationales et
faire en sorte que les paysans français
vivent de leur production
et que la la production soit de je
dirais meilleur que jamais à des prix
qui sont aussi concurrentiels parce que
il est là le sujet aussi c'est que
produire certes de qualité c'est une
chose mais il faut que ces produits qui
soient qui sortent des champs puissent
être achetés par les Français or il y a
un sujet qui est majeur c'est celui
aussi on l'a vu récemment de l'inflation
et quand on voit un ministre et c'est
pas une critique he mais c'est là où
sont les limites du paradoxe si vous
voulez quand on voit un ministre de
l'économie qui se bat en disant voilà le
panier doit pas dépasserel tel prix et
puis qui la semaine d'après dit bah oui
mais on paye pas assez cher nos
agriculteurs bon bah ça c'est les
limites de l'exercice je veux dire donc
faut être un peu réaliste dans cette
histoire là on va pas euh fermer nos
frontières on va pas vivre en culture
vivrière enfin je veux dire c'est
complètement fou ça cette histoire là il
faut simplement trouver les moyens de de
faire une belle agriculture une bonne
agriculture qui soit pas une agriculture
trop trop polluente et une agriculture
qui soit à pter du portefeuille des
français ce qui serait bien c'est qu'on
puisse en discuter en fait parce que
depuis que j' depuis que ce débat est
sur la table en fait l'argument c'est ah
vous voulez revenir à l'Albanie ben non
on veut pas revenir à l'Albanie on veut
discuter les finalités de la politique
agricole c'est pourquoi on cultive
aujourd'hui des terres en France donc on
peut essayer d'en avoir d'avoir une
discussion sans nous renvoyer à
l'Albanie à l'autarciie à je ne sais
quoi non je dis pas qu'il ne faut rien
exporter ce que je pense c'est qu'il y a
une question par exemple sur ce que nous
impor exportons et de respecter
davantage le cycle des saisons et le
deuxième point que je et je pense que
vous avez tout à fait raison Yve de dire
que il y a une question aussi de pouvoir
d'achat alors il y a deux enjeux
là-dedans le premier c'est que ça ce qui
serait bien c'est que on pense que il
faudrait donner un peu plus d'argent aux
salariés en France parce que un des
problèmes si on le bio par exemple c'est
écroulé c'est parce que les gens gagnent
pas assez d'argent on est devant une
popérisation on le sait des salariés
français c'est c'est une autre question
on peut pas oublier un un champ de du de
la réflexion quand on passe à l'autre
sujet ça c'est la première chose et puis
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faudrait
aussi s'interroger sur le fait qu'on
fasse appliquer par exemple la loi
égalim c'est-à-dire le fait queon paye
et qu'on force la le les les grands
distributeurs et les fabricants de
produits transformés issus de
l'agriculture à leur juste prix et ça je
veux dire la puissance publique peut
intervenir pour faire respecter cette
loi qu'elle a elle-même promis qu'elle
fait pas là mais non ce qu'elle fait pas
c'est d'ailleurs quand quand Bruno le ma
et gabrielal disent on va multiplier les
contrôles on va prendre des sanctions
qui ront jusqu'à 2% oui c'est ça c'est
ce qu'elle ne fait donc pas c'est il ils
reconnaissent qu'elle ne fait donc pas
donc on verra s'ils le font on verra
s'ils appliquent parce que quand même
Bruno leemire c'est quand même le
monsieur qui est très aimable avec les
grands dirigeants des groupes
industriels pour leur demander s'ils
veulent bien s'ils veulent bien
augmenter les salaires s'ils veulent
bien arrêter de distribuer des
dividendes et investir dans l'outil de
production sils veulent bien bah là il
faudrait pas qu'il veuille bien il
faudrait qu'il le fasse c'estd qu'on
aimerait bien avoir un gouvernement qui
a autant d'exigence et de sévérit é à
l'égard de du respect de sa loi par les
grands groupes industriels que il n a à
l'égard par exemple des chômeurs en fin
de droit puisque c'est à l'ordre du jour
aujourd'hui de leur ratiboiser encore
leurs droits on va revenir sur la
question a chose aussi c'est que il y a
des évolution dans les modes de
consommationin on consomme beaucoup
moins de viande que par le passé enfin
il y a il y a il y a une transformation
aussi de la demande qui évidemment les
agriculteurs doivent s'adapter à ça et
c'est pas simple on va revenir sur la
question écolo puisque les annonces du
gouvernement ont fait bondir les
écologistes le gouvernement a-t-il
sacrifié l'écologie au profit de
l'agriculture puisque le gouvernement
Alex il est accusé de recule l'écologie
oui on le rappelle Gabriel Attal a
premièrement annoncé l'abandon de la
hausse de taxes sur le gazol non routier
et puis il a également annoncé la mise
en pause du plan écofyo du gouvernement
qui a pour objectif de réduire l'usage
des pesticides dans nos champs de 50 %
d'ici à 2030 une mise en pause de 3
semaines pour le moment alors forcément
et bien cette annonce elle a entraîné
les critiques de la gauche et des
écologistes on va écouter Sandrine
Rousseau qui était sur notre plateau ce
matin on n' pas besoin de mettre en
pause un plan qui vise à diminuer la
part des phyosanitaire dans l'agri en
intrant dans l'agriculture je rappelle
que non mais quel est le message qui est
envoyé quel est le message qui est
envoyé c'est que le problème c'est le
plan écophyo on a plus d'oiseaux on a
plus de verre de terre on a une
biodiversité des sols qui est en train
de s'effondrer il y a des clusters de
cancer d'enfants dont on soupçonne que
les causes soient liées aux
pesticides V voilà face à ces critiques
des écologistes et bien le gouvernement
se défend il n'y a pas de recul
écologique écoutez Marc
fen pas un recul parce que dans le
budget du ministère de l'Agriculture par
exemple il a 1,2 milliards d'euros qui
sont prévus pour faire quoi pour réduire
les produits phytosanitaires pour
planter des pour faire de la
diversification protéin pourquoi parce
qu'on a besoin en Europe d'avoir des
protéines la puse c'est pas la marche
arrière ou alors je comprends rien à ce
que sont les vitesses dans une voiture
la posuse c'est pas la marche arrière
voilà on a compris c'est pas la marche
arrière peut-être au point mort du coup
en tout cas le gouvernement semble
vouloir assouplir les règles françaises
en matière de pesticides pour être au
même niveau que les concurrents
européens écouz le ministre de la
transition écologique Christophe béch ce
que nous disent les agriculteurs dans ce
domaine peut-être avec encore un peu
plus de force que dans d'autres c'est il
y a des règles qui s'appliquent en
France on est dans un contexte de
concurrence européenne et M et les
règles qui s'appliquent chez nous ell
s'appliquent pas parfois à nos voisins
allemands italiens Belg et elle
s'appliquent encore moins à des gens qui
nous font déjà du dumping social mais
qui en plus ajoutent maintenant du
dumping environnemental donc vous voulez
retirer les règles françaises ce que
nous disons c'est que sur ce sujet il
faut qu'on s'efforce d'agir davantage en
européen et l'exécutif cherche notamment
à changer d'indicateurs pour mesurer les
pesticides et adopter un indicateur
européen qui est peut-être un peu moins
exigeant que l'indicateur français
actuel voà voilà on a entendu Marc F la
pause c'est pas la marche arrière est-ce
que c'est pas un faux procès qu'on fait
au gouvernement bah non parce que je
pense qu'en fait le problème que poait
Sandrine Rousseau c'est le message qui a
été envoyé c'est qu'en fait ce qu'on a
indiqué c'est que le problème c'est
d'aller dans un le sens de davantage de
protection de la nature de la
biodiversité et de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est qu'on a
expliqué parce qu'il y avait quand même
tout un débat autour de quel est le et
d'ailleurs qui n'est pas clos he quels
sont les racines de cette crise et là la
proposition du gouvernement c'est les
racines de cette crise c'est la
burecratie si l'écologie bon ben d'une
part je pense que c'est faux et d'autre
part je pense que ça veut dire que nous
ne sommes pas capables d'enclencher sur
ce moi ce que je pense être le premier
grand conflit social autour de la
transition écologique le le message qui
a été envoyé c'est on fait Mar on arrête
on n pas capable de faire donc on on au
lieu d'aller de de chercher comment on
avance on dit on arrête et vous verrez
que en effet ce qui a été très bien dit
par le ministre de la transition
écologique c'est on va essayer deire
faire baisser toutes les réglementations
à l'échelle européenne ben franchement
ça renvoie à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure peut-être que on pourrait se
poser la question de se donner des
règles à l'intérieur de notre pays je ne
dis pas pour remettre des frontières
mais que notre production à nous qu'on
ne lui donne pas comme objectif d'être
en concurrence avec les les productions
des autres et de d'exporter c'est-à-dire
de s'aligner avec les les normes
environnementales et sociales les plus
basses Yve est-ce que le gouvernement a
sacrifié l'écologie au des
agriculteurs oui c'estàd qu'il a il a
remis un peu de réalisme à mon avis dans
le dans le dans les tuyaux euh je CIS
pas parce que il faut quand même vous
savez il faut être réaliste dans la vie
vous allez sur un marché la la la
ménagère elle va faire quoi celle qui a
pas trop les moyens et ben elle va
acheter les tomates espagnoles qui sont
deux fois moins cher que les tomates
françaises donc et les tomates
espagnoles elles sont deux fois moins
chères pourquoi parce queelles ont des
règles de production qui sont deux fois
moins cont traignante que les tomates
françaises il est là le sujet donc je
dis pas qu'il faut moins d'écologie il
faut sans doute mieux d'écologie il faut
surtout être faut arrêter d'être
théorique il faut être très pragmatique
dans cette dans cette situation là donc
ce qu'il faut c'est essayer de
d'harmoniser les règles du jeu qui sont
les règles du jeu européennes et puis
aussi être beaucoup plus exigeant dans
les dans les accords de libre échange
avec d'autres continents et d'autres
pays qui ne sont pas dans l'Union eurne
pour faire en sorte que il y ait pas de
distorsion de concurrence mais soyons un
peu réaliste parce que là on là
aujourd'hui c'est l'heure de
l'agriculture mais le jour où on
va être dans une crise de l'automobile
ce qui est déjà le cas aigu on va dire
ah bah oui mais on a loupé on a loupé le
Mercosur pourquoi parce qu'il y a tous
les produits qui sont en qui sont en jeu
he dans les dans les dans les accords de
libre échange donc vous voyez on est
complètement il faut arrêter la
schizophrénie il faut faut être un peu
réaliste et voir vraiment ce qui est
possible de faire Alex et juste sur les
règles du jeu européennes on peut dire
aussi qu'il y a également une mise en
pause peut-être de la baisse de l'usage
des pesticides au niveau européen avec
une prolongation de l'utilisation du
glyphosate pour les 10 prochaines années
une autorisation qui a été validée et
puis également cet objectif un peu le
même que le plan écofyo he de réduire de
50 % les pesticides d'ici à 2030 le
Parlement européen avait débattu d'une
loi pour et bien fixer cet objectif
cette loi a été rejetée donc il est
vraiment une mise en pause au niveau
européen oui il y a aussi une mise en
pause au niveau européen certes alors en
revanche qui est faux et ce qu'on
narrête pas de dire en France c'est la
surtransposition des des des règlements
et des décisions européennes une très
bonne un très bon papier d'ailleurs que
qu'on peut consulter sur
publicsenat.fr montre que c'est pas vrai
que si on regarde bien la pas une
surtransposition pas supérieure en tous
les cas à ce qui à ce qui se pratique en
Allemagne et dans d'autres pays européen
un dernier mot là-dessus Catherine il
faut plus de réalisme ce que dis ah oui
oui moi je pense qu'il faut du réalisme
et le réalisme c'est qu'on peut pas
continuer comme ça voilà c'est ça qui
est la réalité c'est que on est devant
un mur qui est le mur du de la de
l'effondrement de la biodiversité comme
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure Sandrine
Rousseau de réchauffement climatique
mais les premiers qui sont concernés
ceux qui vont souffrir concrètement
c'est les agriculteurs s'il y a plus
d'eau si on a plus un sol complètement
appauvri qui ne pe peut plus rien
produire ils vont pas y arriver donc il
faut changer ça c'est le c'est le
réalisme
incontournable va terminé par un mot de
politique est ce qui s'est passé ce
weekend et notamment du côté des
républicains puisqu'il y en a un qui
voit loin jusqu'à 2027 c'est Xavier
Bertron qui a fait un très grand pas
vers une candidature à la présidentielle
on va l'écouter il était l'invité hier
soir de BFM une élection présidentielle
est une rencontre c'est vrai pour une
élection municipale pour une élection
régionale mais plus encore pour une
élection présidentielle et je pense que
c'est ça que je ne changerai pas je
continuerai à creuser sillon et puis il
y a aussi d'autrre chose c'est que il y
a la question je pense que nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui de davantage de bon
sens à la tête de l'État c'est ça qui
est très important on voit
qu'aujourd'hui le bon sens semble être
présent sur le terrain et on voit toutes
les difficultés qu'il y a pour prendre
des décisions de bon sens or les
décisions de bon sens sont celles qui
entraînent les Français et je pense que
d'ailleurs il y a aussi un autre aspect
c'est qu'il faut avoir un projet qui
soit pas un projet catalogue ça ne sert
à rien je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
besoins de nos concitoyens c'est
l'autorité c'est de savoir si le travail
reste toujours une valeur qui permet de
s'en sortir de réussir h et puis la
vraie boussole c'est l'avenir des jeunes
voilà Xav Bertrand qui est prêt pour
2027 Yve est-ce que le le calendrier de
l'annonce est surprenant est-ce que
cette annonce est opportune
B je dirais que il est assez il a je
dirais qu'il a pris date et ça ça ça
annonce pour lui une longue campagne
hein puisque non ce ce qui est sûr c'est
que on pensait enfin on pensait certains
pensent que ce sont les élections
européennes qui servent de thermomètre
si je puis dire ou de baromètre et que
c'est après cette élection européenne
que les uns et les autres à droite à
gauche enfin un peu un peu partout se
déclareront et commenceront à affuter
leurs arguments lui décide de le faire
avant cette élection ces élections
européennes on pense évidemment à le
rvoquier qui lui ne cache pas ses
ambitions et attendait le de voir ce qui
se passait aux élections européennes
mais est-ce que du coup là il complique
la tâche aux républicains puisque pour
Éric sooti c'était luren voquer le
candidat vous savez ça va pas se passer
au niveau des républicains cette
histoire euh il va y avoir de mon point
de vue il y aura trois blocs pour les
élections l'élection présidentielle vous
aurez un bloc d'une droite nationaliste
Zemour Le Pen et peut-être quelques
autres un bloc de la gauche de la gauche
autour de Mélenchon moi je reste
persuadé que ça sera lui qui sera le
candidat et puis au milieu vous aurez un
bloc central un bloc central dans lequel
et bien vont concourir peut-être une
dizaine de candidats et c'est c'est bien
leur malheur parce que il
risquent si s'il n'arrivent pas à
s'entendre et bien de faire le jeu des
deux autres blocs qui sont des blocs
mortifère pour l'avenir de la France me
semble-t-il donc on va voir mais dans ce
bloc là bah il y a à la fois la majorité
présidentielle il y a leslr et aussi une
partie du Parti socialiste alors je sais
pas si a une partie du Parti socialiste
ça c'est allé vite en besogne par contre
je suis d'accord avec ce que vient dire
y trard c'est qu'en fait il va y avoir
un candidat qui va rassembler la droite
et euh euh ce qui est s'appelle encore
la macronie mais qui ne s'appellera plus
la macronie puisqu'il y aura plus de
Macron donc il va bien falloir trouver
un candidat ils vont chercher un
candidat et je crois que Xavier Bertrand
comprend que la campagne est lancée
c'est-à-dire que la nomination de
Gabriel Attal et son démarrage euh en
fanfare réavive un tout petit peu cette
question et puis on attend aujourd'hui
le résultat du procès de François Berrou
qui ne ne cache pas non plus ses propres
ambitions donc en fait laissz partir
trop les autres c'estàdire ne pas
rentrer dans l'équation ça fait que les
les les les gens commencent à réfléchir
sans vous alors lui il dit bah non il y
a le maire du Havre il y a le premier
ministre il y a le président du monais
mais il y a peut-être l'ancien président
de la République Nicolas Sarkozi dont on
dit que certains que il pourrait être le
le recours il y a le président de la
région renalp et ben il y a le président
de la région nordpatcalé et lui il pense
qu'il a des arguments en tant que
président d'une région populaire qui
fait face au Front national donc il a
des arguments à mettre dans la balance
et je crois qu'en eff fait comme vous le
dites on n'attendra pas les élections
européennes pour le juge de paix la
question le le paysage en tout cas de la
droite du centre et de la droite ENF qui
est le centre droit lui il est clarifie
enfin il se il se dessine par contre ce
qui n'est pas dessiné c'est le candidat
et vous et je pense que Marine Le Pen
par exemple bénéficie d'être vraiment
très très haut dans son camp c'està-dire
que ça lui donne un un un un poids
politique supplémentaire le fait d'avoir
réuni d'une certaine manière d'avoir
plié le match avant que le match
commence et donc ils vont vouloir
essayer d'activer moi c'est mon
impression est-ce que les républicains
rentrent encore un peu plus dans une
période de turbulence il y a cette
candidature de Xavier Bertrand il y a
aussi le fait que la suite du remanement
est attendue et que des débauchages de
LR et notamment de sénateur LR ne sont
pas exclus c'est sûr que l'avenir des
républicains il est compliqué parce que
euh on voit qu'il y a quand même des
d'abord il y a il y a des une course des
ambitions il y a des désaccords de aussi
il y a ils sont pas tous sur la même
longueur d'onde hein ils pensent pas
tous la même chose et à mon avis il y en
a une partie qui est très Macron
compatible qui pourrait très bien
travailler avec la majorité actuelle et
puis une autre partie qui cherche à
conserver l'identité des républicain
puis encore une autre partie qui elle
est radicalement beaucoup plus
conservatrice et qui l'affiche
sans avec fermeté on le voit avec
François Xavier bami qui est une figure
du parti républicain et qui d'ailleurs
devrait normal normalement tirer la
liste aux Européennes et qui représente
une sensibilité certaine les
républicains c'est pas un bloc
monolitique et comme tout parti c'est
compliqué à faire vivre tout cel on
suivra tout ça on regarde ce qu'il a la
de nos quotidiens régionaux avec
[Musique]
Alex et Alex dans le contexte de crise
agricole dont on a parlé les
agriculteurs préparent le salon de
l'agriculture mais sans forcément grand
enthousiasme oui le cœur lourd avant le
salon c'est le titre à la Une du journal
L'Union même si les annonces du Premier
ministre ont mis fin à la colère
agricole au tracteur sur les autoroutes
et bien les agriculteurs se rendront fin
février au 60e Salon International de
l'Agriculture ils se rendront à ce salon
avec beaucoup d'amertume Jean-Luc
pruveau producteur de lait dans l'aine
l'explique dans le journal L'Union je le
cite la base du mouvement est toujours
en colère les mesures présentées par
Atal sont des bricoles cela ne
solutionne pas le problème de fond celui
de la rémunération je le cite hein ce
sera chaud patate quand les politiques
vont venir au salon prévient-il le
sourire de nos agriculteurs sera en
revanche réservé aux Français en visite
même si il s'agira aussi de faire passer
un message au au consommateurs autre
sujet le bilan du brexit c'est à la Une
des Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace mais
oui cela fait 4 ans que le brexit a été
appliqué 8 ans 8 ans qu'il a été voté
par référendum et c'est aujourd'hui la
déception pour les Britanniques exemple
à Boston la Boston anglaise he une ville
sur la côteest de l'Angleterre celle qui
a le plus voté pour le brexit 75 % des
voix à l'époque et les habitants sont
aujourd'hui amers comme cet ancien
barman je le cite je me suis trompé si
c'était à refaire je voterai pour rester
dans l'Union européenne les brexiteurs à
l'image de Boris Johnson nous ont nous
ont menti en effet un le système de
santé britannique s'est dégradé la
l'inflation a frappé de plein fouet le
pays et puis pour ceux qui pensaient
voter brexit et voter contre
l'immigration et bien les flux
migratoires n'ont pas été mieux
maîtrisés à prendre autrement c'est de
Nice Matin et oui Nice Matin s'est
intéressé aux méthodes pédagogiques
innovantes dans la région niissoise avec
par exemple et bien un menton un cours
de géométrie sous forme de jeu
d'orientation dans la cour de récréation
he cela permis de mieux se représenter
les formes dans l'espace ou encore et
bien à Nice un outil numérique qui
favorise la lecture collective et à voix
haute de beaux textes de la littérature
he cela stimule davantage
l'apprentissage que la lecture à
silencieuse et individuelle et puis à
Nice encore des enfants du cours
élémentaire qui font des potagers en
forêt en permaculture cela les
reconnecte à la nature et cela les sort
un peu de leur mode de vie sédentaire et
dominé par les écrans et puis Orian ont
finit peut-être et bien par la Une de La
Provence et du Progrès de Lyon désolé
consacré et bien à la défaite de
l'Olympique de l'Olympique de Marseille
hier contre Lyon 1-0 désespérant pour la
Provence om Lyon Lyon qui gagne un mode
un match en mode guerrier cétait la une
du Progrès de Lyon merci Alex merci
beaucoup la Figaro démographie les
leviers pour tenter d'enrier la chutier
oui alors la démographie qui a un
problème dans toute l'Europe d'ailleurs
c'estàdire dans le Figaro la revue
regard et cette question le monde
existe-t-il encore bah c'est précisément
ladion que nous don d'avoir c'estce
qu'on est capable de refaire un monde en
commun c'est à lire d' regard merci
caththerrine TR merci je très d'avoir
été avec nous merci beaucoup Alex à
demain prochain rendez-vous c'est à 18h
Thomas H sens public et n on se retrouve
demain très bonne
journée